avant l' affaire du médiator voici celle
de l'isoméride
leur point commun des médicaments coupe
en consommer par des millions de
personnes en france
une toxicité avérée et une
commercialisation par les laboratoires
servier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 1985 l'isoméride est mise sur le
marché
dix ans plus tard sa dangerosité et déjà
révélé dans une enquête internationale
rp l'agencé française du médicament
restreint sa prescription l'isoméride ne
sera donné qu'à l'hôpital et uniquement
dans des cas d'obésité grave la position
a été durcie simplement du fait de la
mise en évidence d'un lien entre la
survenue d'hypertension artérielle
pulmonaire donc une maladie pulmonaire
vasculaire qui est rare mais grave du
fait de son évolution
souvent mortelle malgré ses effets
secondaires avérés ce n'est que deux ans
plus tard en 1997 que l' agence du
médicament retire définitivement
l'isoméride de la vente nouvelle étude
scientifique confirmait les précédentes
valley aux états unis la food and drug
administration a reçu un certain nombre
de cas d'atteintes des valves cardiaques
parfois sévères chez des patients qui
étaient traités sur une plus ou moins
longue période
en 1998 un nouveau rapport d'expertisé
faisait le lien entre l'isoméride et la
mort de 30 personnes dans le monde en
france les premiers témoignages de
malades émerger anne apollos en faisait
partie
ils m'ont annoncé qu'ils me fallait une
greffe des poumons
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de guérison
pour cette maladie et a été revue à
l'état de finale je ne vais pas plus
longtemps à dire qu'est ce que vous
allez faire maintenant bien maintenant
j'essaye de me battre pour que ça se
reproduise tout pour se battre contre
servier des malades de l'isoméride se
regroupent et porte plat
en 2002 après une opération du coeur une
greffe des poumons et quatre ans de
procédures judiciaires
anne apollos obtient gain de cause le
géant pharmaceutique est condamné à lui
verser une indemnité de 400 17000 euros
c'est une décision qui sera amené à
faire jurisprudence sur les
responsabilités des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et les laboratoires
servier feront appel de cette décision
ni en tout lien de causalité entre
l'isoméride et les malades
mais en 2006 la cour de cassation
confirme la condamnation le groupe
pharmaceutique sera encore plusieurs
fois condamné à indemniser des malades
mais aussi des familles de personnes
décédées
[Musique]